MANO MARKS: Hi.
I'm Mano Marks.
Welcome to another Google
Maps Developer Relations
Screencast. In today's tutorial,
I'm going to be
discussing the MarkerClusterer
utility library.
If you have a lot of markers,
your map can look cluttered
and be difficult to use.
For instance, try picking out
the right marker to click from
this group of markers.
Lots of markers can also slow
down your application.
The more markers you have, the
more the browser has to work
to render those markers,
especially in older browsers.
MarkerClusterer solves both
these problems. In its
simplest form, MarkerClusterer
replaces geographically
clustered icons with a single
icon that tells you how many
markers are in the group.
Let's take a look
at this example.
As you can see, there are blue
markers with numbers on them
to indicate how many
markers are
represented by this cluster.
As you click on one of those
icons, the map zooms into the
group of markers and
splits them out.
If the markers become
sufficiently spread apart,
they will appear as individual
markers.
In this case, you can see that
some of the markers appear as
you get closer, and some of
them group themselves into
other clusters.
MarkerClusterer is customizable,
too.
In this sample, we have
customized the icons, the text
color, and the size based
on the number of markers
represented by the cluster.
Let's take a look at the basic
code to get you started.
Go to the Google Maps API loader
and the MarkerClusterer
code and add in some JSON
that allows you to
build markers later.
Next, create the map.
Then create a bunch of markers
by iterating over the JSON
that you loaded earlier.
Don't set them on
the map, though.
Just put them into an array.
Finally, we push the array into
a MarkerClusterer object.
Now let's take a look
at the results.
As you can see, this
is the first sample
that I showed you.
We just rebuilt it.
So all you have to do, create
the markers, and
add them to an array.
Then add the array to a
MarkerClusterer, and it will
handle all the clustering
for you.
OK, so your next step is to go
over to the utility library
documentation and check out the
MarkerClusterer library.
You can click on this
link, and it'll
take you right there.
And there's lots of great
information in there, samples
you can use.
And then just start building
your own clustered
applications.
You can also check out this
article on our documentation
that gives more complete
description of how to do
clustering and different
techniques for dealing with
too many markers.
So I look forward to seeing
the work that you did.
Thanks for listening.
Bye.